-You know, our next guest
from shows like
"The Big Bang Theory"
and "True Blood."
She stars in "Night Court,"
which airs Tuesday nights
at 8:00, right here on NBC.
Let's take a look.
-I know that what I did
wasn't technically "legal,"
but I was pushing boundaries
like I do with you.
It's why we're friends,
and you love that
about me.
-I don't love that about you!
I don't even like you!
-But I'm Baby Heather!
-Your Honor, in light
of this contentious discourse,
I'm wondering if maybe you would
consider recusing yourself?
-Oh, you think?!
-Please welcome back to the show
Melissa Rauch, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
Welcome back.
-Thank you.
-How are you?
-I'm good.
How are you?
-I'm lovely.
I'm so happy to have you here,
back in the East Coast.
-I'm back on the East Coast.
-Grew up in New Jersey.
-Jersey, Jersey.
-Yeah!
-Jersey in the house!
-I hate when that happens.
It's always the very back row.
[ Laughter ]
-That's where Jersey sits.
Those are my people.
-[ Laughter ] Exactly.
-Hi.
-Yeah!
-That's my family.
-Now, you -- We have children
of similar ages,
and I'm wondering,
do you -- are you seeing
any of your own insecurities
in your kids
as they get a little bit older?
-It's interesting.
I do feel like being a parent
just brings up any
unresolved issues that you have.
And I'm realizing that I have
some majorly unresolved,
like, latent bullying issues
that I never got over.
Like we were recently
at a kid's birthday party
at, like, a "paint
your own pottery" place.
And this kid came up to me
and he was like,
"We were all talking.
We want to know,
are you an adult or a kid?"
[ Laughter ]
And I -- I felt so triggered,
and I genuinely wanted to know
who he meant by "we."
And it came out as,
"Oh yeah?
Who wants to know?
Who's the "we"?"
[ Laughter ]
And my husband was like,
"That's a little aggressive.
That's a preschooler."
And so -- Ad I was like,
"Okay, I'm gonna reset."
And I said, "You know,
people come in
all shapes and sizes.
And I happen to be
on the smaller side."
He's like, "Oh, no,
we all know you're short.
We've seen you. It's just
you're covered in paint."
Alright
.
[ Laughter ]
-So it was about
being bad at painting.
-It was about being, like --
and just dripping myself
in paint like a toddler.
Yeah.
-By the way, nothing says
you're from New Jersey
more than,
"Oh, who's the 'we'?"
-Exactly.
-Yeah.
-"Come on, you tell me."
-"Who's this 'we'?"
-I like that you also wanted
to roll up the whole group.
You're like, "I can't just
cut off the head of this thing."
-Oh, no.
-I got to figure out
who these are.
-Exactly, it's gonna pop up.
-Exactly.
You're gonna use him
against -- to testify
against the others?
-Exactly.
-What's it like now
when you go back home?
You still have family here
when you visit new Jersey.
Is it nice?
-It's so nice.
It's very nice being back home.
We do a lot of, like,
looking through old home videos
and showing them to my kids.
My mom actually pulled out
an old home video of a community
theater production of "Annie."
A very Jersey "Annie."
-Now, you were Annie.
-I was Annie.
-How old is this Annie here?
[ Audience awws ]
-I'm about 13.
-Alright.
And so what's a Jersey "Annie"?
-It's a lot of
♪ Ta-morrow, ta-morrow ♪
♪ I love ya ta-morrow ♪
That's Sandy.
It's my dawg, Sandy.
[ Laughter ]
-No, I have to say, like,
I kind of only want to see
New Jersey "Annie" now.
-It's pretty great.
It's pretty great.
I might revive it.
Jersey, you ready?
-Yeah. There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Both laugh ]
Alright, so, another thing is,
which I'm very delighted by,
your mother has been
trolling you.
Now, first of all,
I'm very impressed
because she's trolling you
with a meme,
which is so beyond
the comprehension of my mother.
Like, I don't even think
she'd know
what any of those words mean.
-That's what's so --
It's completely shocking,
because it's very much
not like my mother.
So someone must
have showed her.
Maybe those kids from the
pottery party have gotten her.
But she sends me
these pictures
whenever I'm on the phone
with her
or saying anything
that I'm saying with confidence,
that I'm maybe not
100% correct with.
She sends me this meme from me
on "Celebrity Jeopardy!,"
where I was not sure
of my answer.
-And so you said this
on "Celebrity Jeopardy!"
-I did.
-"Yes, I'm sure about it."
Now, this was an actual moment
that became a meme
because everybody watching
knew you weren't sure.
-Exactly.
And I knew I wasn't sure.
-Okay, gotcha.
Do you remember
what the question was
that you were not sure about?
-I don't remember,
I think I completely blacked out
on that entire experience.
-Yeah.
-Anything that -- Just
the idea of being questioned --
it didn't matter
what the question was --
it was so much pressure.
-I will say,
we're both performers,
we've been in front
of an audience.
That strikes me
as the most stressful thing
you could possibly do.
-It was.
And it's also for charity,
so you really want to do well.
And any question they ask,
I'm [Laughing nervously].
It's terrifying.
-Did your charity reach
out afterwards
and say, like, "Thanks, uh,
for nothin'"?
-Nothin'.
[ Laughter ]
Luckily, it's a charity
that I started,
so I was letting myself down.
-Oh, gotcha.
So it was a racket.
-Oh! [ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
So let me -- Just to clarify,
you started a charity
for yourself...
-Two win "Celebrity Jeopardy!"
-...and then raised money for it
on "Jeopardy!"
Okay, great.
Congratulations.
-I'm from Jersey!
What do you want?!
-"Hey, I'm from Jersey!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
I mean, really, that would be --
It would be so funny
if there had been
a "Sopranos" episode
where Tony starts
his own charity
and goes on "Jeopardy!"
[ Laughter ]
-[ As Tony Soprano ]
It's for a good cause.
"Yeah, give me a break!"
[ Normal voice ] So, your
cos-tar, who was in the clip,
the great John Larroquette,
a giant in comedy,
also a physical giant.
-He is, he is.
-I could not believe it.
I think he's 6'4".
-He's 6'4".
-He towers over me,
and I tower over you.
[ Laughter ]
So, what is it like on set
with the great John Larroquette?
-It's -- It's the best,
but it's I also feel
there's a major imbalance
in our relationship,
because I, like you said,
I get to work
with the amazing
comedic force that is John.
He is brilliant in every way.
He's 6'4".
He's got this voice that is like
this hot brick of butter.
Like, he's just - He's amazing.
And he saunters onto set
and everyone -- just your eyes
go to him
because he's this incredible,
powerful human being.
And I also think about John,
you know that song
"Where Have
All the Cowboys Gone?"
-Yeah.
-I believe
that they have gone
in to John Larroquette.
-He holds
all the old cowboys?
-Yeah.
He's just a cowboy.
He's so -- He's just
a powerful presence.
Me, on the other hand,
I hang on him
like I am an Elf on the Shelf.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm so excited
to see him every day,
that I get to work
with this man,
that I greet him like an excited
cocker spaniel every day.
"John, how you doing?
How was your weekend?
Wanna have lunch?
Wanna talk? "
And he's so kind
and so wonderful with me
and, like, just graciously
accepts me
hanging on him and my hugs.
But our wonderful writers
on the show
came up with a line
for the season premiere,
where he says to my character,
"You're like a puppet
I wouldn't want to buy."
And, like, it just encapsulates
our entire relationship.
[ Laughter ]
-You have wonderful
guest stars on the show.
Um, that was Jessica St. Clair?
-Yes, one of my best friends
in real life.
-And she's just a delight.
And then one of your
"Big Bang Theory" co-stars here.
And so just tell me
when someone like Kunal
comes on the show, like,
in front of a live audience,
it just must be such a delight,
like the "Big Bang Theory" days.
I mean, people must go nuts.
-It was a dream.
When he came out,
the audience didn't know
that he was going to be
appearing in that episode,
and they went absolutely wild.
And I was just so filled
with delight that he was there.
And we had the best time
all week.
It was just like old times.
Even that picture actually
was a moment after --
Kunal is one --
He is just pure heart.
He's one of the most spiritually
enlightened people I know
and just the most down-to-earth,
wonderful human.
He's also one of the most
impeccably dressed humans
that I've ever met.
-That's a very --
It's a real nice coat.
-Yes, it's a beautiful coat.
And he, for years,
has given me a hard time
about how I roll into work.
For years
on "Big Bang Theory,"
he showed up to set here --
and I'm a producer
on the show, too --
and he's like, "Melissa. Still.
You're a producer now.
You're people's boss.
Please put on something nice!"
And Lacretta,
who plays our wonderful bailiff,
she was like, "Well, you guys
aren't dressed too differently.
You're both wearing black.
He's like,
"What are you talking about?
Like, this is nuts!
I am in designer clothing,
and she's in Forever 21!
This is not okay!"
And so that picture was taken
after he gave me a hard time
for my sweatpants.
-He's a little upset about it.
-He's so angry at me.
-What a delight
to have you back.
-Thank you.
-Congratulations
on the continued success
of the show.
-Thank you so much. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Guys, this is
our friend Melissa Rauch.
"Night Court" is Tuesday nights
at 8:00, here on NBC.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."